For almost as long as there have been video
games, there have been film tie-ins.
As a rumoured landfill filled with Atari ET
games can attest, the games don’t always
live up to the source material, but on the
flip side of that, some games actually manage
to eclipse the films they’re based on.
While that may not be the case with every
game on this list, we think all of these games
did a pretty admirable job of capturing the
essence of the films that inspired them.
Here are 10 Amazing Video Games That Were
Inspired By Movies
Spiderman 2
While the Spider-Man franchise has had its
struggles over the years, the closest the
films ever came to getting it exactly right
was 2004’s Spider Man 2.
Fortunately the game followed suit, and New
York became a gamer’s ultimate playground
as Peter Parker dealt with struggles big and
small.
The web slinging achieved what so many games
before had attempted, and while the side missions
are fun, it’s also nice to just go for a
leisurely swing around manhattan’s skyscrapers.
Ghostbusters
If you’re a movie geek but you don’t really
follow gaming, it may shock you to find out
that gamers were basically treated Ghostbusters
3 back in 2009 when all four of the original
Ghosbusters voiced their characters for the
multi platform game.
Set two years after Ghostbuster 2, the player
gets to be a fifth Ghostbuster in training,
basically fulfilling every 80s kid’s fantasy.
Dan Aykroyd and the late Harold Ramis, who
wrote the original films, even contributed
heavily to the game’s story and dialogue
to add to the game’s slimy authenticity.
Fast and Furious
Before Dom and his family became international
spies, the Fast and the Furious franchise
was all about one thing: street racing.
So of course the arcade game based on the
first film was a straight-up racing game,
and one worth getting to the theatre a little
early for.
The Fast and Furious arcade game was an unofficial
successor to the Cruis’n USA series, a fact
the makers can make no bones about since
they changed the name to Cruis’n when they
ported the game over to Wii after their licensing
for the film had run out.
Aladdin
What could have just been a generic side scrolling
adaptation of the latest animated Disney hit
actually ended up being one of the biggest
and best games of 1993.
Aladdin’s game designers were able to incorporate
cell animation from the actual Disney animators
who worked on the film for a much more vibrant
look than gamers were used to in those days.
Kids who thought they were too old or cool
for a Disney game probably missed out on this
diamond in the rough.
Goldeneye
It’s almost not fair to include Goldeneye
on this list, as its legacy and impact as
a game has surpassed that of the film it’s
based on.
This game predicted the demand for multiplayer
shooter games before it was possible to play
them online.
Along with Mario Kart, Goldenye best represents
that small window in video games’ history
when it was truly a group activity.
The single player gameplay was decent and
somewhat faithful to the film, but Goldeneye
will aways be remembered for it’s fun multiplayer
features like “slappers only” and the
advantages of being Odd Job.
Dune II
Dune II makes the list not for it’s faithfulness
to the source material, of which there’s
little, but for pioneering Real Time Strategy
games.
Only loosely connected to the plot of the
films and books, Dune II had players building
and commanding armies to control the desert
world of Arakis.
The team behind this game would later apply
this kind of gameplay to the hugely successful
Command and Conquer series.
Michael Jackson’s Moonwalker
The 80s were a strange time and few personified
it better than the king of pop, Michael Jackson.
The man was a brand with almost as many merchandising
tie-ins as Star Wars.
It’s kind of faded into obscurity now, but
some of us still remember his film Moonwalker,
a collection of Jackson-centric vignettes
that were basically extended music videos
released as a feature film.
Of course there was a video game with Jackson
dancing his way through various levels while
saving children.
It sounds silly, but this side-scroller was
oddly addictive.
Tron
Was there ever a more appropriate movie to
base a video game on than Disney’s 1982
gamer fantasy Tron?
Following a computer programmer who gets sucked
into his own program, the 3D look of the film
and early use of CGI predicted the future
of video games and movies.
Aimed squarely at the burgeoning gamer demographic,
it’s no surprise that the arcade tie-in
was hugely successful.
Kids voted with their quarters and Electronic
Games magazine declared Tron the Coin-Operated
Game of the Year.
Tron remains one of the few recorded examples
of the game making more money than the movie
it was based on.
Jurassic Park
While the Sega Genesis Jurassic Park game
may not have a legacy quite as impressive
as the film, it was certainly a worthy tie-in
and one of the better home console games in
the early 90s.
One unique feature was the option to play
as either Dr. Alan Grant or a velociraptor.
While the levels were the same, the gameplay
was quite different depending on if you chose
to be the hero or one of his ferocious antagonists.
In a time when saving your game wasn’t an
option, the game utilized passwords for every
level so that players didn’t always have
to start at the beginning.
That might not sound like a big deal, but
today’s gamers definitely take always being
able to pick up where they left off for granted.
Star Wars
While Mel Brooks may have made fun of him
for it in Spaceballs, you gotta hand it to
George Lucas for inventing multiple revenue
streams by merchandising the heck out of Star
Wars.
Not only did he cram in ample characters to
maximize toy sales, he also got in on the
ground floor of gaming by crafting sequences
which leant themselves perfectly to the new
technology’s limits.
Released in 1983, the first Star Wars game
contributed to the Golden Age of Arcade games
and is still considered one of the most popular
games of all time.
Those are just some of our favorite videos
games that were inspired by hits from the
big screen.
What are some of your favorites?
Were there any we missed?
Sound off in the comments and don’t forget
to subscribe to our channel for more awesome
videos like this one.